eskalation am golf die usa töten gezielt
einen iranischen top-general teheran
droht mit vergeltung haftbefehle gegen
vier männer sie sollen an den
silvesterball in leipzig beteiligt
gewesen sein
und karl geiger bleibt dran
der oberstdorfer springt auch bei der
qualifikation in innsbruck vorne mit
einem gesamtsieg der vierschanzentournee
scheint weiter greifbar
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster gegen abend und willkommen
bei den 19 uhr nachrichten an diesem
freitag christian otto ist für den sport
an meiner seite
genau wie schön guten abend in der nacht
haben us-soldaten einen hochrangigen
iranischen militär gezielt getötet mit
einer drohne im nachbarland irak general
kassim soll immer nie soll laut
us-angaben attacken auf amerikaner in
der region geplant haben
damit eskaliert der konflikt zwischen
den usa und dem iran weiter auf
gefährliche weise general soll immer nie
war einer der mächtigsten männer im iran
ein enger vertrauter von staatsführer
kamen er führte seit jahrzehnten die
al-kuds-brigaden eine eliteeinheit die
für alle militärischen aktionen
außerhalb des landes verantwortlich ist
damit war soll ihm an irans
strippenzieher in der region unter
anderem im irak in syrien im libanon und
dem jemen
die usa machen soll im money für den tod
hunderter us bürger verantwortlich
peter jäger auswaschen ein luftschlag am
flughafen der irakischen hauptstadt
bagdad präzise ausgeführt von den
amerikanern das ziel der wagen des
iranischen generals soleimani der dort
gerade angekommen war
er stirbt gemeinsam mit einem
hochrangigen irakischen milizenführer
der angriffe von us präsident persönlich
angeordnet worden
die iranische staatsführung reagiert
scharf
der geistliche und politische führer des
landes ayatollah khamenei spricht von
vergeltung ähnlich der iranische
parlamentspräsident wenn sie einen
großartigen brillanten kommandeur
umbringen sollten die amerikaner sich
der konsequenzen ihres handelns bewusst
sein
sie bringen eine unsicherheit in die
region und sie werden selbst schaden
erleiden
in vielen teilen des iran trauer um den
getöteten prominenten general bei den
freitagsgebeten und demonstrationen
gegen die usa wut auf den straßen
mit gottes hilfe werden wir den
amerikanern einen solchen
vergeltungsschlag verpassen
dass man darüber später noch in den
geschichtsbüchern lesen wird wir lieben
den general er ist wie unser eigen
fleisch und blut
wir wollen dass unser führer ihn mit
allen mitteln recht sonnemann ii soll
hinter den gewalttätigen angriffen auf
die us-botschaft im irak stecken
schiitische milizionäre griffen das
gebäude am dienstag an die
botschaftsmitarbeiter mussten fliegen
auch der irak verurteilt nun die us
aktion scharf spricht von einer
verletzung der souveränität des landes
die us regierung dagegen rechtfertigte
den angriff
wir wollen dass die welt versteht dass
eine attacke unmittelbar bevorstand das
amerikanische volk soll wissen dass
diese einschätzung auf informationen des
geheimdienstes basiert us-präsident
trump twittert solle man nie habe
geplant viele weitere menschen zu töten
sei aber geschnappt worden und er übte
kritik an der iran politik seiner
vorgänger
der iran hat noch nie einen krieg
gewonnen aber noch nie eine verhandlung
verloren
doch vor allem von den demokraten hagelt
es kritik der us präsident habe den
angriff ohne die zustimmung des
kongresses befohlen
der demokratische
präsidentschaftsbewerber beiden spricht
von einer enormen eskalation die das
risiko eines krieges erhöhen
die us regierung ist in
alarmbereitschaft rief ihre bürger nun
dazu auf den irak so schnell wie möglich
zu verlassen
fragen wir unsere auslandskorrespondent
in washington und istanbul zuerst mrt
sind in washington immer was will trump
etwa einen krieg mit dem irak mit dem
iran
eigentlich will er keinen krieg glaube
ich er kann die bilder von getöteten
amerikanischen soldaten den wahlkampf
sicherlich nicht gebrauchen
ihm geht es darum das prinzip der
abschreckung neu zu etablieren
es gab ja zweifel an der
entschlossenheit der us-regierung als
tramp im vergangenen jahr einen
militärschlag gegen den iran kurzfristig
abgesagt hatte
danach gab es eine menge gewaltsamen
provokationen durch den iran und jetzt
eben das signal bis hierher und nicht
weiter trump hätte auch einen luftschlag
gegen ein militärisches ziel im iran
befehlen können
stattdessen nun doch die sehr drastische
maßnahme dieser tötungsaktion ganz
offenbar gegen eine person gerichtet die
vielleicht sogar die zweitwichtigste im
iran ist zur abschreckung und ob diese
abschreckung dann funktioniert das liegt
allein in der hand des iranischen
regimes wenn es gewaltsam antwortet dann
droht natürlich die eskalation in einen
ausgewachsenen krieg auf denen die usa
sich vorbereiten sie entsenden jetzt so
melden medien hier in den usa zusätzlich
schon einmal 3000 soldaten in die region
gehen wir nach istanbul zu halim hosny
der oft im iran war heil in teheran
droht ja nun mit massiver vergeltung wie
könnte die aussehen nun die iranische
führung hat mehrere möglichkeiten
militärisch zu reagieren möglichkeit
eins wären direkte angriffe auf us
militäreinrichtungen hier in der region
beispielsweise im irak hier in der
türkei in jordanien katar oder bach rehn
ob sie diese möglichkeit sieht scheint
eher unwahrscheinlich
möglichkeit zwei angriffe auf us
verbündete beispielsweise israel aber
nicht nur denn die iranischen raketen
reichen bis nach europa und möglichkeit
drei angriffe auf ölförderanlagen haben
golf beispielsweise saudi arabien und
das würde die weltwirtschaft mit
sicherheit stark beeinflussen und wenn
man sich das ganze an schaut seit
gestern scheint hier die zeit scheint
hier die zeichen tatsächlich auf
eskalation
düstere szenarien vielen dank halim
hosny danke elmar theveßen
die tötung des iranischen generals löst
weltweit große besorgnis aus
uno-generalsekretär gute risch warnt vor
der gefahr eines neuen golfkrieges den
sich die welt nicht erlauben könne und
auch die europäische union fordert den
kreislauf aus gewalt provokationen und
vergeltung zu beenden
die bundesregierung mahnt zur
besonnenheit david sauer
die amerikanische botschaft in berlin
wie immer streng bewacht jede
us-vertretung ist jetzt ein potenzielles
ziel
einen krieg verhindern fordert die
bundesregierung also zurückhaltung auf
beiden seiten kommt es darauf an mit
besonnenheit und zurückhaltung zu einer
deeskalation beizutragen das
amerikanische vorgehen ist eine reaktion
auf eine ganze reihe von militärischen
provokationen wie die der iran
verantwortung trägt die beziehungen
zwischen usa und iran sind seit 40
jahren schlecht die jüngste krise nahm
ihren lauf im mai 2018 us-präsident tram
kündig das atom abkommen mit iran auf
nennt es den schlechtesten deal aller
zeiten und verhängt schwere
wirtschaftssanktionen im juni 2009 10
dann explosionen auf zwei tankern im
golf von oman
die usa machen dafür iran verantwortlich
ebenfalls im juni schießt iran eine us
spionage drohne vom himmel
das pentagon reagiert empört sagt die
drohne sei in internationalem luftraum
geflogen
september 2009 10 die größte
ölraffinerie saudi arabiens geht in
flammen auf die usa die traditionell das
saudische königshaus unterstützen
vermuten dahinter die rahn und jetzt
also die tötung einer der wichtigsten
iranischen führungspersonen durch die
usa
das wird jetzt ein moment sein in dem
die gesamte nation gewissermaßen auch
diese rache und vergeltung fordern wird
und die radikalisierung des landes ist
denke ich auch unvermeidbar dadurch dass
jetzt eine gezielte tötungsaktion der
amerikaner erfolgt ist ist diese anti
amerikanismus noch mal gestärkt und so
beobachten sie in berlin und auf der
ganzen welt wann und wie iran antwortet
alle aktuellen entwicklungen in dem
konflikt haben wir im live blog auf
heute.de dort finden sie auch eine
dokumentation über den getöteten general
sulimani und seinen aufstieg vom
bauernjungen zum mächtigen
strippenzieher in der islamischen welt
in der nähe von paris ist ein mann
offenbar wahllos mit einem messer auf
passanten losgegangen
dabei tötete er ein mann und verletzten
mindestens zwei weitere personen eine
davon schwer
tatort war ein öffentlicher park in der
gemeinde will griff einem vorort südlich
von paris
die polizei
schoss den täter auf der flucht sein
motiv gilt noch als völlig unklar
wegen der angriffe auf polizisten zu
silvester in leipzig ist gegen vier
männer haftbefehl erlassen worden
den beschuldigten im alter zwischen 27
und 32 jahren werden unter anderem
tätliche angriffe und körperverletzung
vorgeworfen
diskutiert wird nun wie der
linksextremen gewalt in leipzig am
besten zu begegnen ist stefan kech der
in der silvesternacht verletzte polizist
konnte die klinik heute verlassen
es habe keine not operation gegeben
damit korrigiert die polizei
ursprüngliche aussagen
dennoch habe die gewalt gegen polizisten
nun eine neue dimension erreicht was wir
bislang in leipzig connewitz erleben ist
ein vorläufiger höhepunkt von gewalt und
auseinandersetzung wir haben seit
einiger zeit in leipzig ein problem ein
problem mit gewalttätigen gewaltbereiten
linksextremisten
wir haben das problem vorletztes jahr
auch angegangen
durch eine entsprechende polizeipräsenz
noch über den nutzen einer solchen
polizeipräsenz sei eben zu reden meint
die spd vorsitzende saskia esken
sie kritisierte gestern die leipziger
polizei und wurde ihrerseits dafür
heftig kritisiert
dann sage ich dass mir das leid tut dass
so eine interpretation natürlich
vollkommen falsch ist es geht mir nicht
darum polizeibeamtinnen und
polizeibeamte zu kritisieren in ihrem
handeln sondern es geht mir darum
wirklich in frage zu stellen ist da
genug personal dabei gewesen und ist
auch die vorgehensweise an welche orte
begibt man sich und wie geht man mit der
mit der eskalation um
ob das auch die richtige gewesen ist in
connewitz gibt es seit jahren angriffe
auf polizisten alle versuche dieses
viertel zu befrieden scheiterten
allerdings bislang arbeitet in connewitz
mit einer sozialpolitik wie wir sie auch
in anderen stadtteilen haben um menschen
die es hier geht die andere menschen
massiv brutalst angreifen auch den tod
in kauf nehmen da brauche ich keine
sozialpädagogik mehr das ist durch das
ist gegessen da kann ich nur noch mit
polizei arbeiten und da ist einer
kommune sind dort die hände gebunden
gegen vier männer erließ ein richter
mittlerweile haftbefehl
dennoch werden weiterhin zeugen der
vorgänge in connewitz gesucht
am arbeitsmarkt macht sich mittlerweile
die schwächere konjunktur bemerkbar
das zeigen die neuen zahlen der
bundesagentur für arbeit
im dezember waren zwei millionen 227.000
menschen ohne job also 47.000 mehr als
im november
die arbeitslosenquote lag bei 4,9
prozent im vergleich zum dezember 2018
waren 18.000 erwerbslose mehr
registriert bemerkenswert denn einen
anstieg im vergleich zum vorjahresmonat
hatte es zuletzt 2013 gegeben
alexander pohl mit einzelheiten die
bäume wachsen nicht mehr in den himmel
so fasst die bundesagentur für arbeit
ihren ausblick auf das jahr 2020
zusammen eine verbesserung der
wirtschaftlichen lage sei zwar denkbar
für ein deutliches beschäftigungsplus
aber fehlen schlicht die menschen 2009
10 haben wir noch mehr als 220.000
zusätzliche erwerbspersonen zu
verzeichnen gehabt 2020 erwarten wir ein
plus von 40.000 das ist faktisch null
der fachkräftemangel ist mittelfristig
die eigentliche wachstumsbremse in
deutschland das wirkt sich auch auf die
zahl der sozialversicherungspflichtig
beschäftigten auswirken
sie stieg in den letzten elf jahren
kontinuierlich an
von 27 millionen auf heute 33 millionen
dass es so bleibt unwahrscheinlich denn
vor allem in den technischen berufen in
der informatik und dem maschinenbau gibt
es zu wenige berufseinsteiger aber nicht
nur dort ein hoher bedarf an
arbeitskräften besteht insbesondere im
pflege und gesundheitsbereich und da
haben wir das problem dass viele
menschen die dort mal anfangen relativ
früh auch wieder aussteigen weil die
arbeitsbedingungen dort sehr
lasten sind während es also vielerorts
an fachkräften fehlt herr strand
politischen verwerfungen kein mangel
nicht gelöste handelskonflikte der brh
exit oder der nahe osten die
ungewissheiten nehmen zu auch darin
sehen experten eine gefahr für den
arbeitsmarkt im jahr 2020 das schwimmbad
geschlossen der jugendclub verweist
traurige realität in vielen deutschen
kommunen
sie werden von ihren altschulden schier
erdrückt und können sich solche
einrichtungen nicht mehr leisten
der deutsche städte und gemeindebund
will nun dass bund und länder in die
bresche springen und die schulden der am
schlimmsten betroffenen kommunen
übernehmen ähnliches hatte schon
finanzminister scholz vorgeschlagen
frank buchwald kaiserslautern hat
deshalb getroffen traditionsreiche
industrie längst weg nur die schulden
sind geblieben mehr als 11.000 euro
lasten rein rechnerisch auf jedem der
100000 einwohner viel zu viel für
kaiserslautern und kein einzelfall
der deutsche städte und gemeindebund
ruft deshalb nach hilfe von bund und
ländern
wir brauchen eine lösung nicht wegen der
kommunen wir brauchen die lösung wegen
der menschen ob mein kind erfolgreich
ist in einer guten schule ist darf nicht
davon abhängen ob ich ihn erreichen oder
arme kommune leben das sind
gleichwertige lebensverhältnisse die wir
wollen und zu denen sich auch bund und
länder bekennen
hilfe für überschuldete gemeinden diese
idee hat bereits bundesfinanzminister
scholz ins gespräch gebracht zuletzt vor
weihnachten gibt sehr viele kommunen in
deutschland die so hohe schulden haben
das heute klar ist sie werden diese
schulden nie wieder los werden und nie
wieder genug luft zum atmen zu haben um
zb zu investieren in die kommunale
infrastruktur in schulen zb und wir
brauchen einen solidarischen beistand
für die das ist mit entschuldung
verbunden 50 milliarden könnte das
kosten je zur hälfte von bund und
ländern
einige länder haben jedoch eigene
entschuldungsprogramm oder nun nicht
doppelt zahlen hessen etwa oder bayern
wir bleiben dabei wir helfen gerne aber
die hausaufgaben in bayern wurden
gemacht und wir zahlen nicht für andere
die bisher nichts getan haben
kritiker bemängeln außerdem ein
schuldenschnitt segen eine unsolide
ausgabenpolitik nachträglich ab aber wer
über die verhältnisse bewusst gelebt hat
der muss natürlich in der
konsolidierungsphase anders behandelt
werden als diejenige der wirklich
unverschuldet in diese krisenhafte
situation geraten ist damit auch städte
wie kaiserslautern eine chance auf
zukunft haben
bei den schweren überschwemmungen in
indonesien ist die zahl der todesopfer
auf mindestens 43 gestiegen
viele menschen werden noch vermisst in
der region um die hauptstadt jakarta
hatte es zum jahreswechsel extrem stark
geregnet
zehntausende mussten ihre häuser
verlassen in einigen gebieten geht das
wasser zwar wieder zurück für die
kommenden tage sind aber weitere heftige
regenfälle angekündigt in australien
dagegen treiben verheerende brände
zehntausende in die flucht viele
einheimische und touristen haben sich an
die strände gerettet weil sie dort von
den feuern eingeschlossen wurden hat die
marine im bundesstaat victoria hunderte
menschen über das meer in sicherheit
gebracht und schon morgen könnte sich
die lage weiter verschärfen weil mit
einer neuen hitzewelle gerechnet wird
und jetzt zum sport an diesem freitag
christin und gleich mal zur
vierschanzentournee karl geiger fliegt
weiterhin von mit bei der qualifikation
für das dritte springen am bergisel in
innsbruck bestätigte er mit platz drei
seine konstant gute form und bleibt die
große deutsche hoffnung auf den
ersehnten gesamtsieg
der daumen geht auch nach der
qualifikation hoch bei karl geiger er
nimmt einen dritten platz nach 131 5
metern mit in das morgige
wertungsspringen viel wichtiger aber
geiger hat sich vom training bis zur
qualifikation bei jedem sprung
gesteigert
am anfang ist schwer tun mit dem chancen
rhytmus tisch hier doch eigen aber haben
wir gut darauf eingestellt und der
dritte der college provide 16
noch besser machte es der sieger des
neujahrsspringens der junge norweger
marius link gewinnt mit der gleichen
weite wie geiger die qualifikation am
bergisel vor dem österreicher stefan
kraft
zweitbester deutscher stephan leyhe auf
rang 10 markus eisenbichler wer hier im
februar weltmeister geworden war wird
zwölfter und rund um skispringen ganz
viel wintersport morgen von 11 5 am inn
zdf sportextra enttäuschung bei den
deutschen tennisspielern unter teamchef
boris becker unterlagen sie zu beginn
des neuen ep cups gastgeber australien
nach der auftaktniederlage von jan
lennard struff ist alexander zverev im
spiel gegen alex seminar gefordert den
ersten satzgewinn 12 6 zu 4 in zweiter
verpasste die chance auf eine 5 2
führung verliert ihn im tie break und
nach seinem rätselhaften einbruch und
zahlreichen doppelfehlern verliert auch
die nerven
das gehört zum tennis das habe ich
gemacht das haben viele hand gemacht und
es hat ihn auch die ersten vier spiele
dritten satz gekostet
satz 3 verliert 12 26 auch das doppel
credit suisse unterliegt australien
gegen griechenland am sonntag droht dem
dtb schon das aus beim neuen 15
millionen dollar turnier foyer und bald
beginnen schon die australien open zum
wetter erwarten uns morgen regen und
schnee die details sehen sie gleich bei
es intern so viel für heute danke für
ihr interesse
claus kleber erwartet sie mit dem heute
journal heute erst gegen kurz vor elf
wir sind dann morgen wieder pünktlich um
sieben zur stelle
einen schönen abend noch für sie
[Musik]
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die auswertung des
deutschen wetterdienstes zeigen dass
ganz eindeutig die letzten 30 jahre
waren die wärmsten bisher seit 1881
die letzte dekade hier angedeutet im
rechten balken das war die wärmste
bisher dieses mehr an wärme das sorgt
immer häufiger für
extremwetterereignisse auch bei uns in
deutschland schauen wir auf das aktuelle
wetter und da sehen sie regen im süden
nach südosten kann der sogar gefrieren
ganz im norden gibt es schauer und
stürmischen wind sonst klart es auf bei
temperaturen von minus ein grad im
vogtland und 6 grad im südwesten
deutschlands
morgen am vormittag kommen noch mehr
wolken von norden ins land es regnet
ganz im süden lässt der regen nach im
westen lockert es auf zum nachmittag
wird ziemlich ungemütlich da kann es
durchaus bis ins flachland schneien
sonst in schauer unterwegs und im
bergland gibt es ebenfalls schnee bei
höchsten temperaturen von zwei grad im
vogtland und 8 grad im nordwesten
die nächsten tage am sonntag gibt es im
norden deutschlands noch etwas regen
sonst wird es trockener bei zwei bis
acht grad und der montag wird ziemlich
sonnig damit ein schöner abend